[Music]
hey everybody its charlie Hawkeye is
back I've been getting so many ronan
video requests so this is gonna be all
about hawkeye zark and where he picks up
during Avengers 4 there's a new round of
the Infinity war blu-ray giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this recently Jeremy Renner said that
he's getting ready to suit back up again
this was just about a month ago when he
posted this so he's mostly talking about
the Avengers for reshoots which we're
gonna start late in the summer which is
right now basically finishing up in
early September so they're almost done
with all the reshoots and they're mostly
just doing small touch-up scenes
usually it's just character moments to
bridge the really big action set-pieces
those are some of the first things that
they actually start shooting because
visual effects takes so long they finish
principal photography on Avengers 4
earlier this year they started editing
it the week that infinity war hit
theaters back in April what they've done
for Hawkeye story is combine a couple
really big comic book arcs that sounds
complicated but the movie itself will
not be complicated
so it's house of M comic book Civil War
the infinity saga with the Infinity
Gauntlet of course and Secret Invasion
with the scrolls so the whole reason why
he became Ronin in the comics is because
after the events of Civil War he was
brought back to life he had been erased
by Scarlet Witch during house of M no
more mutants
even though Hawkeye isn't a mutant he
was killed during that event but then
when reality was restored later after
her Scarlet Witch got her [ __ ] together
he was brought back to life so he
mysteriously came back so you can see
how that's kind of a parallel for Thanos
his finger snap
when he was brought back to life civil
war had already gone down Captain
America had been killed in this crazy
red skull plot that intersected what was
happening during Civil War so Ironman
offers him the mantle of Captain America
because he feels like it's a big symbol
and Hawkeye would be good candidate he
tells him to go screw himself leaves and
joins the New Avengers and takes the
road and mantle because one of their
early missions is to go rescue the
former Ronin character who's named echo
from the silver samurai the hand in the
Yakuza from the Japanese underworld so
he was joining the New Avengers for this
ninja art to rescue the former Ronin but
also this was still during the period
when the superhero Registration Act was
enforced so he needed to hide his
identity so he couldn't just be
straight-up Hawkeye the Skrulls Secret
Invasion stuff came a little bit later
but during infinity war in ant-man the
wasp
they both name-drop ant-man and Hawkeye
saying that they cut deals with
Thunderbolt Ross relatively quickly
after the events of Captain America
breaking them out of the raft and they
can clearly find us we need all hands on
deck where's Clint after the whole
Accord situation he and Scott took a
deal was too tough on their families on
house arrest so a man went and made box
forts with Cassie for the past two years
Hawkeye has been living on his farm
raising baby Quicksilver Pietro Barton
and his other son and daughter with his
wife Laura played by Linda Cardellini as
of Civil War he was ready to retire
anyway so Hawkeye was probably totally
happy to cut that deal so when we get to
infinity war in the actual snap this is
where the ronan arc from the comics
changes a little bit for the movies
hawkeye stakes in this or his family you
get a feeling like the avengers are
number two on his priority list like he
loves being an Avenger in saving the
world but really he mostly just cares
about his family like he didn't even
tell the other Avengers about them until
he was forced to when he brought them to
his farm so the beginning of infinity
war they have all these scenes with the
characters that introduced them and let
you know what's going on in their lives
and let you know what their personal
stakes are like Tony has that big scene
where he talks about getting married to
Pepper when Thor ship is intercepted by
Thanos he was on his way back to earth
because you know Hulk wants to come back
and live a normal life
Thor wants to create new Asgard for his
people so you get the idea
everybody is called to action when
they're things that they care about
their personal stakes are threatened the
people or the things that they're trying
to accomplish at the end of ant-man in
the wasp we learned that Hawkeye and ant
man's house arrest is up right before
the finger snap goes down because he
goes down into the quantum realm fingers
snap happens that was almost moments
after he had gotten off of house arrest
so you have to imagine that while
ant-man is getting his bracelet taken
off in this same simultaneous moment
it's happening with Hawkeye on his farm
too so he's free and clear but you kind
of see where I'm going with this like
the one thing that would light a fire
under Hawkeye's ass would be threat of
losing his family so early prediction
his family was probably erased in the
finger-snap which pissed him the hell
off and called him to action the movie
reason for him wearing that Ronin
costume being the Ronin character has
more to do with that original comic book
Ronin story where he was going to Japan
to fight the Yakuza in the hand in the
events of comic book secret invasion so
that part has more to do with hawkeye's
comic-book family which during Secret
Invasion was the Mockingbird character
they had been married in the past so
even though they've been divorced she's
been missing he's worried about her she
mysteriously shows up climbing out of
this alien spaceship that's landed on
earth and it turns out that she's a
scroll along with a bunch of other
heroes so full-blown Secret Invasion the
movie version of the scrolls are being
introduced in the Captain Marvel movie
which is set during the 90s but as for
Scrolls in present day during the events
of Avengers 4 there were only reports
from the set that Hawkeye dressed as
Ronan was filming scenes with Japanese
Yakuza types who would be wearing
prosthetics as in making it sound like
they were doing a combination of that
original Ronan story where he first
debuted as that character mixed with the
Secret Invasion storyline so you can
kind of see the same way that they did
with infinity war Avengers 4 is
combining a whole bunch of different
comic-book stories
it sounds more complicated than it is
though the movie itself will be pretty
easy to follow despite all the crazy
twists that Chris Hemsworth has been
teasing I think it'll be relatively
simple to follow at the end of the day
like you remember that clip they just
dropped of him supposedly spoiling the
plot of Avengers 4 as if he thank you
give you a couple spoilers for Avengers
4 I'd love if you and your friends keep
this secret okay first one is for has a
new weapon in event is for okay it's his
thing yeah the other secret is the movie
is going to be called said we have to
because it's true so that's no way the
movie
I can't thank you enough depends enough
this is just brilliant and I wish I was
there and art with you all I'm sorry but
thank you again I love you all cheese so
hopefully that explains a little bit
about Hawkeye's rodent character comes
into the story but remember at the
beginning of the movie they're still
living with the loss of all these
characters so this isn't slowly
reforming the team and rebuilding their
shattered lives literally shattered
lives in some cases so let me know in
the comments what are you most hype
about for Hawkeye Ronin like I said
they're still doing Avengers for
reshoots right now so I think it's still
gonna be a long time before we see any
actual footage from it Captain Marvel
trailer will be the first thing that's
up I'm not really expecting that till
October though but if I hear anything
more about footage dropping or Avengers
4 titles or anything like that I will
totally do a video about it
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner from my last big video Joshua
Everhart please email me on the back
into my channel so I can get your
contact details click here for that new
spider-man trailer that just dropped and
click here to learn about Marvel's plans
for Deadpool and Fantastic Four once the
Disney deal goes through thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]